hi my name is usman I'm five years old
and today I'm having two chefs compete
to make my dream dish how are you
I'm Hannah this is alice ice to meet you
ha ha we heard a little secret about you
we heard that you might be an ice
princess do you know what an ice
princess would eat it's family
it was very low as snowballs which no
that's a good kind of suit I'm thinking
that's doable
sweet usually it's the way to go so so
what's your favorite kind of snowball
flavor vanilla type MBL's dice cute this
was their grass in this winter land yeah
yeah man
cucumbers cucumbers okay ice cream and
cucumber I really don't understand how
this is going to come together doesn't
really go together in my mind these are
the shines that make it shiny okay okay
do you like fruit what's your favorite
room Lynch oranges do you like pineapple
oh yeah this is the Sun these are the
stars this is the bread and this this of
the snow these are the cucumbers these
are the grass and these are the yellow
lines don't make it shiny there's a lot
going on here but if there's one thing
I've learned in this competition it's to
not leave anything out I think that we
have everything we need to make you
something truly a basis no tastic
lanch of a picture this is gonna be a
breeze
freeze let's see who the winter is of
this competition like winner
let's go so here's my plan
I won last time based off of the
simplicity of my dish so I'm gonna keep
it simple again this time for the
sandwich I'm doing toasted bread with
butter and sugar and two different
flavors of little ice cream scoops
inside for the grass I'm doing a green
buttercream for the stars and the Sun
I'm doing cut up pieces of mango and
pineapple and for the shimmers I'm just
gonna do edible glitter all right here's
my plan for the snowball sandwich I'm
gonna make vanilla ice cream snow balls
covered in blue coconut and chocolate
waffle base for the stars in the Sun I'm
going to make a very simple open-faced
cheese sandwich and for the grass and
the shiny step I'm gonna use sweetened
coconut and color it green and yellow
Hannah do you think it's to win this
competition you'll still let me swim in
your pool I'll think about it
Alex and I are very good friends we joke
that she's my daughter she's my third
child and it's like my mom I just don't
know how I'm supposed to compete against
her I am going to have to let go of my
maternal instincts and affection towards
her which I don't think I'll be able to
do are you making waffles from scratch
no they're the waffles I'm gonna be
using pancake mix but I'm adding cocoa
powder and chocolate chips to it to make
it a chocolate waffle she seems to like
chocolate as balls
so hopefully that works out in my favor
so I have this star cookie cutter and
I'm going to cut stars out of value
pineapple and some mango but I don't
want to get the core of the pineapple in
here and this star cookie cutter is like
a little too big to avoid the core so
hopefully she doesn't bite into the hard
part I haven't quite figured out what
I'm going to do for the
son but as long as the stars are turning
out okay I'm good
oh my gosh is this even gonna work oh no
I mean it's doable
it's pretty bad the mangoes are not
working out they look really weird so
I'm scrapping it so we're going to pull
pineapple for the stars this mango is
gonna be my Sun because it's not really
working as a star oh it's so good you
can use this for your cheese can I eat
it go off if I mess one up you cut it
I'm going to be using a fancy waffle
maker to get the waffle shape I
genuinely don't know how to use this
there's like two it spins okay here we
go I have to do two waffles I feel like
I'm gonna maybe need more batter how
much you know the amount of effort I put
into my kids meals at home this like
makes me feel guilty
my youngest can never find out that I
have done the show because he is already
a picky eater and if he catches wind of
this he's going to be demanding this for
every meal okay this one's definitely
sticking to the top of this thing oh man
oh man you know what I could still use
it though it'll be the bottom sandwich
but how she didn't pick it out girl so
now that my waffles are cooked I am
going to move on it to assembling the
Stars for the stars and Sun I am using
simple white bread spreading some
mayonnaise on top layering that with a
slice of cheddar cheese and then cutting
out the Stars and the Sun shapes so I
know it's a little weird to go with an
Ice Cream Sandwich but I'm just gonna
give her what you wanting oh you're
putting mayonnaise on that no manis next
to ice cream just weirds me out a little
bit but the more I think about it the
more a kid would probably be stoked
because it's kind of like the best of
everything you know what she said Manny
Manny this is weird but I'm putting
mayonnaise on No
like the mayonnaise there are two
strategies in this competition give the
kid what they want given what you think
they want today I'm giving her what she
was Wow look at this little cheese bread
star oh that's so cute
now I'm gonna job my snowman friend he's
made of snow and there's 20 snowballs
that's his body he has stick hands and
he is my friend me pray items see can I
borrow a couple pieces of bread only if
you do the chicken dance really thank
you oh my god I cannot believe I did
that cook it on side Hannah is so much
fun I mean we just get to chat and hang
out let's see how I can toast this bread
this is a really important step because
if I over toast it the bread is done for
there's a lot at stake here with this
toast I don't think people realize I
haven't calibrated this toaster well if
I under toast it then I run the risk of
tearing the bread when I spread the
butter on this bread is not durable
have you seen bread shake like this I'm
toasting the bread covering it with
butter and sugar and a tiny bit of salt
just to cut out the sweetness a little
bit the butter sugar ratio is key it's
kind of like snow kind of except it's
gonna disappear what are you making this
side out of I know I guess I'm just
gonna do the same cheese bread we're
just gonna chop off the star legs I
guess oh my gosh thank you it's
literally just cheese bread but I have
something really cool this is edible
glitter I don't know how much of this
you're supposed to use or if it actually
has any taste well that worked great I
don't know if she even likes coconut I
really hope she does but this will give
me good grass texture
I've never colored coconut before so
we'll see how this goes for the grass
I'm coloring sweetened coconut green and
for the shining stuff I'm coloring in
yellow because I really haven't made
anything
I'll make buttercream my buttercream is
like the most basic ever with just
butter powdered sugar and milk and some
food coloring I hate using food coloring
I hate it my philosophy on food coloring
is that parents may not like it but it
works in this competition I don't think
it can't be good for you
this tastes weird oh you know what it
needs and needs a little salt
watch this Alex oh wow so once the
frosting is ready I'm going to put it in
a piping bag with this really awesome
tip that actually has a bunch of
individual holes in it so that when the
frosting squeezes through it kind of
crinkles up like grass Oh the grass
looks so cute so stoked no I'm gonna
start with my snowballs the last thing
to make is the snowballs so I'm gonna be
scooping vanilla ice cream rolling that
in the blue-colored sweetened coconut
you oh my god she used like a big scoop
and I'm gonna use this tiny scoop to try
to make tiny snowballs I'm putting my
bread down for little scoops of ice
cream - vanilla - strawberry and maybe
I'll throw some green sprinkles in there
to imitate the cucumber cuz you know why
not just load her up with some more
sugar already here a little more
put him across down looks like grass to
me the shiny one coconut I really hope
she likes coconut cuz I brought it on
everything there was no point in me
putting green sprinkles on these
snowballs it does not look good so I'm
going very small and simple and Alex is
full-blown Hardy on a platter there is
so much color on it it's very bright and
vivid and lively the more I look at her
dish the more I hate my
it looked better in my head and looks
crazy my looks crazy she might be a
little overwhelmed I guess I should go
see who the next ice queen of the
competition is tinctures display big
brillouin so my dish is very simple it
is exponentially simple but I think I
gave her everything she had on the
drawing and it is food and it is on a
plate but does it look great hmm I think
it should taste good
I'm really proud of my dish I think it
came together perfectly it's exactly
what I had envisioned the snowballs look
like snowballs the grass looks like
grass I've gotten all the elements that
cheese asked for I know the flavor
combinations get a little weird with the
cheese and the ice cream but I hope she
really loves it time for my ice cream
feast like say like the picture put a
shine I did the lines the stars mine was
like the hard ones but they did the
other ones like the easy ones well
that's what pineapple I don't really
like pineapple she says she doesn't like
pineapple do you like pineapple yeah I
might be in trouble now let's taste this
mango I love mango it's my favorite
thing in the world that made me feel a
lot better overall about the dish if you
have a kid's favorite food on there that
ups your chances of winning by far I'd
say oh the grass okay this is gonna be
good it's like frosting
I like frosting she didn't like that I
didn't put lines on the plate but she
did like my grass so I say they cancel
each other out and we're neutral so it
all comes down to this
sugar toast sandwich oh this is heavy
ah it's yummy
it's got ice cream inside my favorite
parts are the mango and the vanilla
oh my god this is awesome
I can hear her exclaim Wow and I know
I've done my job yeah I kind of knew
that was gonna happen
when did wand oh she did the line that's
good and to me the grass Oh who's that
thing there's a lot of coconut on this
dish and I'm banking on the fact that
she likes coconut oh my gosh oh my gosh
and coconut I love coconut it tasted so
delicious
oh she's on bread slippery flip flip
flip oh man this is crazy a crazy day
okay yes I read the non-display it's
delicious that's like shockingly well
she liked everything on the plate she
didn't think it was weird that there was
cheese and bread and ice cream
sandwiches she even loved the coconut I
am ecstatic to see you again
so you tried two dishes today right you
liked it seemed like you liked them both
a lot yeah no okay well if you had to
pick one which one was your favorite the
coconut you get this chef drop hahaha
thank you so much I scream you scream we
all scream for the eyes clean because
Alex beat me she's grounded until my
feelings are no longer hurt so who are
officially crowned
the eye squirrel oh I scream for ice
cream yeah